[Music]
I'm Tyler Florence and this is the great
food truck race let's get rollin
[Applause]
[Music]
he candy cane we saw what you did to
that guy you pathetic lonely reach you
get what fixed
yeah look what I have created our
affairs public forum
[Music]
[Applause]
but seasons come and seasons go I'll
make you smile again if you don't
can't you
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
did you see that they went right through
a roadblock you sumbitches couldn't
close an umbrella
[Music]
one day one day some of the kids from
the neighborhood carried my mother's
groceries all the way home you know why
it was that a respect okay five more
seconds and stop
oh I think I'll stop right here
citizen what is your name my name is
James Tiberius Kirk
[Music]
never made the first jump and now I know
but what if he does he won't
[Music]
what does that mean it doesn't mean
anything everybody falls the first time
[Music]
right
you are so dead
[Music]